we we all carry a narrative
um
someone's lazy
um someone's stupid
someone doesn't care
someone's only in it for themselves
these are narratives that we carry and
the problem is when we evaluate their
behavior through our narrative we it'll
become it will become self-reinforcing
we will see the things that reinforce
our narrative
and the problem is then we'll treat them
that way if we've decided someone's lazy
we're going to treat them as lazy
so there's a great exercise to do which
is literally take out a piece of paper
and when we're struggling with someone
to think what are the 20 other things
that could be going on in their life so
yeah number one they're lazy possible
it's absolutely possible number two
they're having trouble in their marriage
number three their um things have gone
wrong and they and they don't know how
to ask for help number four they're
still struggling with the trauma of
kovid number five their kids are
flunking out of school like
all of a sudden we realize there's a lot
of other reasons that could explain
their behavior and we will then treat
them accordingly we will treat them with
greater empathy
you know instead of walking into
someone's classroom and saying what the
hell your you know your performance is
still down i've had this conversation
with you before you got to get your
performance up or i don't know what's
going to happen
or
you can walk into their classroom and
say your performance is down we've had
this conversation before
are you okay i'm worried about you
we we they have a problem but they
aren't necessarily the problem and even
if ultimately it does become that they
were bad for the culture
they're still they are still not the
problem they still are just a bad fit
for the culture they have a problem we
can help them solve that problem by
going to help them relocate to a
different school district where they're
going to be so much happier we're going
to be so much happier everybody gets to
be so much happier so the other story i
was thinking of is the story of alan
mullally
when he took over ford
ford is losing money hand over fist in
other words performance was in decline
and when he sat down with his most
senior executives
and he asked for a report on how their
divisions were going regular green every
single one of them delivered power
points with all green slides
and he said at the end of the meeting
how can everything be green
if we're losing billions of dollars
and they just sat there
and he had another meeting
same thing all green and he said the
same thing how can everything be green
if we're losing billions of dollars the
problem was the previous leader if you
delivered a red slide you got fired
and so there is no way that anybody was
going to tell the truth
because their job depended on it
and so one executive took the risk to
turn one slide red
and mulally said
thank you for the the the
visibility that's great transparency now
how can we all help him fix that problem
he has a problem he is not the problem
all the other executives thought he was
going to get fired
turns out he wasn't and slowly but
surely
everybody including leadership could
finally get a clear and transparent view
of what was actually going on in their
organization and they worked together to
solve the problems if somebody was
struggling people said how can we help
you rather than i'm fine you're the one
that's screwing everything up so it's a
great way to think about it
you